d'abord bonjour merci à toutes et à tous
d'être là pour cette reprise
enfin reprise ça c'est pas beaucoup
interrompue pendant cette courte période
quelques mots d'abord pour cadrer et
puis ensuite chacun de ceux qui sont
avec moi olivier mas l'ex rachida dati
est naturellement bio mais arrivés
pourront a précisé sur les amendements
sur leur positionnement avant la prise
de mesures allant premier point les
choses soient claires le président
nicolas sarkozy a convoqué un bureau
politique qui aura lieu ce mercredi à
11h et qui sera strictement consacré à
la révision constitutionnelle
par conséquent ce mercredi
le positionnement des uns et des autres
sera évidemment évoqué pendant ce bureau
politique et nous verrons à l'issue du
bureau politique quelle est la position
globale du mouvement par rapport à cette
révision qui est proposée par le
président de la république
deuxième élément si on rentre un peu
plus dans le détail vous avez pu voir
bon très bien
le président la république depuis notre
précédente réunion dans cette formation
de la mission de suivi le président de
la république a donc proposé
si je comprends bien malgré la garde des
sceaux une révision constitutionnelle
intégrant la déchéance de nationalité et
à l'intérieur des républicains
même si certains sont en débat sur
faut-il inscrire la déchéance dans la
constitution ou dans la loi faut-il
réfléchir au chant de la déchéance est
ce que c'est uniquement pour terrorisme
est-ce que c'est uniquement au bout de
la procédure et dans quelles conditions
il ya débat forcément y comprendre nous
ça veut dire quand même que le président
public de ce côté-là avancé il passe par
la voie parlementaire de la réforme de
la constitution et non pas par la voie
référendaire même si la voie
référendaire aurait quand même sous tenu
une première étape parlementaire
ça veut dire qu'il faut les trois
cinquièmes en congrès nous aurons donc à
débattre je vois que le président la
république ou le premier ministre qui en
appelle souvent à l'unité nationale
quand il s'agit de la droite on appelle
assez peu quand il s'agit de la gauche
qui a visiblement explosé en vol
si j'ai bien compris au moins la moitié
de la gauche ne votera pas la réforme
communistes écologistes une grande
partie des socialistes c'est bien de se
tourner vers nous pour nous dire unité
nationale dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
c'est vrai que on voudrait comprendre
comment la gauche va se comporter lors
de la réforme et si l'appel à l'unité
nationale les concernent aussi sur la
réforme elle même
nous aurons un certain nombre de sujets
cpeq globalement on l'a dit nicolas
sarkozy l'a dit alain juppé l'a dit nous
sommes plutôt favorables à la réforme
avec l'état d'urgence et la déchéance de
nationalité mais très logiquement et je
parle sous le contrôle de rachida on
sait très bien que cette réforme
le texte de la réforme est un texte de
principe et que pour être opérationnel
il faut évidemment un texte de loi porté
par la garde des sceaux mettant en
oeuvre ce que le principe de déchéance
qui sera inscrit dans la constitution va
déterminer
dans ces conditions nous sommes quand
même légitime à dire et a demandé
savoir quand le texte aurait déposé par
rapport à la réforme constitutionnelle
et deuxième élément qui aura t-il dans
le texte
comment va être déterminée l'ensemble
des éléments liés aux principes qui
serait dans la forme constitutionnel
mais qui naturellement ne serait pas
détaillé points suivants évidemment
j'entends jean marie le guen dire
quasiment enfin il le dit pas comme ça
mais pas loin pas d'amendement on
propose un texte et c'est le texte tel
quel qui doit être adopté pardon enfin
si on veut une procédure parlementaire
et un débat parlementaire
et s'il ya un débat parlementaire très
naturellement
les républicains en tant que groupe à
l'assemblée au sénat où un certain
nombre de députés ou de sénateurs
républicains auront des amendements les
amendements sont des amendements après
tout si vous ouvrez une réforme de la
constitution qu'on ait un débat pendant
la réforme et au parlement sur qu'est-ce
que la nationalité dans quelles
conditions elle s'acquiert dans quelles
conditions elle se perd s'il ya un débat
sur assimilation et intégration
s'il ya un débat sur les procédures
pénales parce que on a bien compris que
il y avait le symbole c'est la réforme
constitutionnelle
on n'a toujours pas l'application
concrète est ce que la politique pénale
du gouvernement correspond aux
incantations sécuritaire qu'il fait
régulièrement pour le moment non non
donc tous ces débats là seront portés
pendant le débat parlementaire
on verra au terme ce qui sera voté même
si je le rappelle il ya plutôt une
appréciation favorable pour le moment
m'enfin comme tout vote parlementaire il
sera déterminée à la fin du débat
ce qui est quand même assez logique et
légitime voilà donc voyez bureau
politique mercredi
on peut constater d'ailleurs que
position d'alain juppé position de bruno
le maire positions des uns et des autres
finalement
le ski avait été déterminé à l'issue des
conventions sécurité immigration qui
avait été fait ici même pratiquement
avec des nuances
je l'admets enfin pratiquement il ya
maintenant une convergence sur
l'ensemble de la famille politique
alors pas forcément sur les applications
immédiates mais sur les grandes lignes
de la politique pénale sur les grandes
lignes de la déchéance de nationalité il
ya aujourd'hui convergence je ne doute
pas que le bureau politique de mercredi
arrivera à une position assez claire en
la matière voilà donc nous avons sur ce
point une approche constructive
nous ne voulons pas la négation du
parlement c'est-à-dire que nous disons
très clairement réforme
constitutionnelle est elle nécessaire
n'est-elle pas nécessaire c'est une
chose sur la déchéance
oui mais faut-il passer par la réforme
le gouvernement le président république
choisit cette option
on va pas s'opposer pour s'opposer là
dessus mais il ya débat il ya débat et
ensuite dans l'application on ne veut
pas juste un vote de principe parce que
le vote principes de la réforme
constitutionnelle et c'est une chose
on veut savoir ce qu'est la loi qui suit
on veut savoir dans quelles conditions
les amendements que nous pourrions
porter serait reçu par le gouvernement
parce qu'il ya une chose qui serait pas
acceptable je préfère le dire tout de
suite c'est de nous dire que sous le
prétexte que la gauche explose et que
le gouvernement a du mal à assurer des
voix socialistes on serait prié de se
taire pour qu'au moins le solde des voix
socialistes restent sur la réforme parce
que ça deviendrait quand même un peu le
monde à l'envers
c'est à dire que la droite sur le
fondement de la réforme et la gauche ne
serait que les voies supplétives alors
bon j'aime tout le monde et comme le
président la république est en ce moment
précis en train de faire ses voeux je
souhaite qu'ils fassent des voeux aussi
pour sa formation politique pour sa
famille politique pour tous les membres
du gouvernement pour un meilleur lien
cazeneuve taubira pour le fait que je ne
sais pas moi que à gauche
by un peu plus de soutien au
gouvernement pour ne pas nous forcer
nous à faire le travail coiffer un
moment l'unité nationale c'est aussi de
la responsabilité de tous et pas
seulement de la nôtre voilà je vais
passer la parole successivement mais
j'allais dire à mes complices ce n'est
pas le moment peut-être rachida d'abord
et puis ensuite à guillaume et puis
olivier merci roger l'essentiel a été
dit je préfère effectivement qu'on
répond des questions le point sur la
réforme constitutionnelle
évidemment les sujets va être est ce
qu'on met le sujet qui est en débat
actuellement la déchéance de la
nationalité est ce qu'on la met dans la
constitution ou pas sur l'état d'urgence
moi j'ai pas de jets pas difficulté puis
parler de politique pénale tout à
l'heure aujourd'hui la politique pénale
de la france se résume à l'état
d'urgence
il n'y a pas de politique pénale tout
les perquisitions les assignations
toutes les mesures de sûreté de sécurité
qui sont prises aujourd'hui sont sous
couvert de l'état d'urgence absolument
pas dans le cadre d'une politique pénale
qui n'existe pas donc demain si ça
s'arrête tout ça s'arrête et donc les
mesures de sécurité qui vont avec et
donc la sécurité des citoyens
donc ça aussi il faut le rappeler sur la
déchéance de nationalité moi j'ai une
réserve
c'est vrai que je ne suis pas favorable
à ce qu'elle soit inscrite dans la
constitution
parce que d'abord c'est une peine lourde
je considère que la manière dont elle
est présentée par le gouvernement
aujourd'hui elle est discriminante parce
qu'elle s'adresse à des français en
raison d'une origine même très lointaine
où en raison d'une origine ou en lien
avec un pays la personne connaît pas
forcément
donc ça pose aussi une difficulté la
déchéance de nationalité le principe on
y est tous favorables d'abord ça existe
moi j'ai été magistrat
on en a prononcé sa existe et c'est
possible aujourd'hui l'élargir ça ce
serait extrêmement possible par la loi
et en plus on pourrait élargir de
manière beaucoup plus efficace que ce
qui est proposé aujourd'hui dans le
cadre de la constitution parce que de
dire d'être déchu de sa nationalité dans
le cadre de terrorisme le terrorisme
c'est une qualification pénale d'accord
mais au sens large est ce que
l'association de malfaiteurs par exemple
qui est une qualification pour le
terreau les terroristes est-ce que ça
rende en cas de la déchéance quelqu'un
qui est radicalisé la radicalisation
n'est pas une qualification pénale
mais quelqu'un qui est qu à radicaliser
complètement fou et qui n'a qu'une
obsession c'est de s'attaquer à son pays
s'est attaqué aux intérêts nationaux
est ce que cette personne doit être
déchu ou pas de la nationalité est ce
que les violences en réunion pour
s'attaquer aussi à des internationaux
est ce que ça ça doit être ça doit
entrer dans ce champ là donc de dire
pour terrorisme moi je trouve qu'on
brade moi j'ai encore eu un grand
respect pour cette constitution qui pour
moi je vais dire parce que les mots
maintenant ont un sens et je vais dire
un acte encore sacré c'est un acte
suprême c'est une loi fondamentale c'est
la loi qui organise notre notre destin
commun
moi ça me ça me pose un problème
juridique ça me pose un problème
d'efficacité de lutte contre le
terrorisme et de lutte contre la
radicalisation le sujet aujourd'hui
c'est la radicalisation
on parle pour lutter contre le
terrorisme quand on voit tout ce qui
s'est passé en 2015 on en connaît les
solutions les prisons le net les prisons
90% des jeunes qui sont radicalisées
l'ont fait en prison
tous les profils des terroristes que
nous avons eues auquel on nous avons eu
en fer en 2015 ont tous été des
délinquants de droit commun ils sont
pratiquement tous radicaliser en prison
on voit le réseau le réseau s'est pas et
ils sont pas connues en réseau extérieur
uniquement sur le net
ils sont d'abord interconnectés en
prison donc d'abord mettons les moyens
en prison le centre de déradicalisation
dont a parlé monsieur valls passé sos
amitié c'est du genre oui alors on
je suis radicaliser j'appelle et jeudi
j'ai besoin d'être radicaliser vous avez
quelqu'un que vous connaissez vous vous
considérez radicaliser vous appelez vous
dites voilà il radicalise et on
l'appelle en ville ça serait bien de
vous présenter c'est pas comme ça que ça
se passe
donc aujourd'hui en france nous n'avons
pas ni de centre de déradicalisation ça
n'existe pas ça n'existe pas et nous
n'avons pas la méthode de
déradicalisation aujourd'hui c'est des
groupes de parole c'est la thérapie de
groupe
ça n'est pas de la jonction sur des
individus radicalisés radicaliser ou en
voie de radicalisation
il faut que ce soit de la contrainte de
la contrainte nous avons une
hospitalisation de cette systématisation
d'office c'est de retirer deux espaces
publics quelqu'un qui troublent l'ordre
public c'est l'hospitalisation d'office
ont le feu est effectivement hospitalisé
là le sol la déradicalisation et la
radicalisation en prison ce sont des
vrais enjeux et à mon avis plus efficace
que de mettre d'échéance pour
terroristes dans une constitution qu'on
abîmerait au passage en avec une peine
qui serait à mon sens un peu
discriminant et sans champ d'application
on n'en connaît pas du tout le champ et
je trouve que tous ceux qui disent
attention c'est dangereux les mêmes là
veulent aujourd'hui alors que ça serait
plus dangereux l'inscrire sans
circonscrire évidemment le champ qu'on
pourrait faire très aisément dans la loi
que le faire dans la constitution mais
ça c'est ma conviction et c'est
effectivement le débat que nous aurons
au bureau politique mais le principe la
déchéance pour faire très attention
quand on dit 90% à 80% des français y
sont favorables
nous y sommes tous avoir tous favorables
ceux qui s'attaquent à notre pays à ses
intérêts
la déchéance ce principe est acté et
dont nier tous favorables maintenant
quel est le meilleur véhicule pour la
meilleure efficacité très bien
ajoute ce que vient de dire excellemment
rachida que par exemple le premier
ministre lui-même a dit que nous avions
dépassé le cap des 1000 français ayant
fait le jihad et que 250 était revenue
sur le territoire national sauf que on
ne sait pas ce que sont devenus les 250
visiblement j'ai pas le sentiment que
les 250 soit incarcéré donc que se
passe-t-il qu'est ce qu'on a fait
qu'est ce qu'on a fait des 250 français
revenu du djihad et qui sont sur le
territoire national dans le débat
parlementaire guillaume il ya un certain
nombre de positions que tu a défendu et
tu vas nous en rappeler les grandes
lignes
merci ce qui est certain c'est que la
première urgence
elle n'est pas constitutionnelle elle
est opérationnelle
notre obsession c'est de participer à un
effort de protection des français
et ça passe d'abord par des mesures
opérationnelles puissante précise
pratique qu'est ce qu'on fait dans les
prisons rachida a raison de poser la
question on l'a fait aussi à l'assemblée
nationale avec des propositions très
précises
comment fait-on pour séparer les détenus
radicaliser des autres détenus
comment fait-on pour les isolés les uns
des autres
comment fait-on pour qu'il ait pas de
création de cellules de combat dans les
prisons ça c'est un sujet extrêmement
important que le gouvernement en réalité
à écarter d'un revers de main ces
derniers mois elector autres questions
opérationnelles
la mobilisation des effectifs de police
et de gendarmerie
nous l'avons d'ici à quelques semaines
et nous le répétons nous sommes
convaincus qu'il est nécessaire de
mobiliser les réservistes et de les
organiser
le président de la république avait
évoqué à versailles la question de la
garde nationale
on en est où là dessus il part il ya peu
d'organisation d'un effort de réserve
permettant de compléter l'effort des
policiers des gendarmes de deux métiers
l'urgence elle est d'abord opérationnel
mais le président d'un public a fait le
choix lui d'ouvrir un débat
constitutionnel en ou saisissant de ce
projet de loi constitutionnelle adoptée
en conseil des ministres l'avant-veille
de noël mercredi 23 décembre et donc on
est comme parlementaire amener à
réfléchir d'abord à nous prononcer
ensuite on n'est pas une chambre
d'enregistrement
roger karoutchi hier a eu raison de le
dire dès lors que le choix est fait par
le chef de l'état de nous soumettre ce
projet de loi constitutionnelle il est
tout à fait normal que nous leur gardien
et que nous la demandions
aujourd'hui c'est une version provisoire
cette dernière jeunes aiment aller
jusqu'à des actes est un brouillon
juridique je continue à le penser
c'est une version provisoire elle doit
être retravaillé techniquement par la
commission des lois de l'assemblée par
la commission des lois du sénat par les
deux assemblées en séance publique
et puis à diane of the day au bout du
bout
naturellement on verra quel est le vote
d'ensemble que nous aurons les uns et
les autres à effectuer au congrès de
versailles si le président de la
république décide de convoquer le
congrès de versailles s'il pense qu'il a
une majorité de 60 % des parlementaires
pour le faire alors il ya deux questions
constitutionnelles qui nous sont posées
la première sur l'état d'urgence
gouvernement propose de créer un article
36-1 dans la constitution pour au fond
recopié dans la constitution ce que la
loi dit déjà sur les conditions
procédurales de déclenchement de l'état
d'urgence est-ce que ça sert vraiment à
quelque chose il est permis de
s'interroger
l'état d'urgence a été déclaré par une
procédure prévue par une loi simple la
loi de 55 qu'on a modifié en 2015 le
conseil
constitutionnel il n'y a à ce stade rien
trouvé à redire et s'est déjà prononcé
deux fois une fois en 1980 5 et une fois
en 2015
le 22 décembre est ce qu'il est
nécessaire indispensable d'inscrire
l'état d'urgence dans la constitution
c'est une vraie question la vraie
question d'ailleurs c'est pas trop celle
des pouvoirs provisoire lié à l'état
d'urgence que celle des pouvoirs
permanent de lutte contre une menace
permanente qui est la menace terroriste
c'est ça le vrai sujet j'ai d'ailleurs
raison de le dire il se passe quoi
après le 26 février après le 26 février
il ya plus l'état d'urgence il ya
toujours une guerre qui nous a été
déclarée par des ennemis islamistes qui
veulent détruire par la terreur la plus
barbare notre société démocratique on
fait quoi
après le 26 février
la question ne sera pas réglée par une
modification constitutionnelle sur
l'état d'urgence
le vrai sujet c'est quelle sont les
instruments de lutte durable contre une
menace qui est durable c'est pour ça que
nous avons ici sous la présidence de
nicolas sarkozy à plusieurs reprises
notamment lors de la convention sur la
sécurité
on a fait des propositions très précises
par exemple nous on est pour la
rétention de sûreté des terroristes
condamnés en 2008 il ya une loi qui a
été votée sur la rétention de sûreté
pour certains profils de condamnés à des
peines de 15 ans quand rachida dati
garde des sceaux s'agissant des
terroristes y compris quand ils ont été
condamnés à 15 ans qu'est ce qu'on fait
dans quelques mois ou dans quelques
années vous en avez qui sortent de
prison
on en fait quoi on pense que il faut
sans doute créer des centres de
rétention pour les conserver dans un
environnement surveiller de près ça ça
nécessite d'avoir un vrai débat
juridique peut-être constitutionnel en
effet et ça c'est un débat opérationnel
hors de l'état d'urgence mais de manière
permanente
comment on répond à une menace
terroriste permanente
premier sujet donc l'état d'urgence
deuxième sujet cette affaire de
déchéance de la nationalité
nous le disons nous le répétons nous
sommes favorables au principe selon
lequel un français au fond ce exclu
lui-même de la communauté nationale
lorsqu'il commet un acte de terrorisme
au fond c'est ça et sans faire de
philosophie politique le contrat social
de rousseau tous à tout ce qu'on a
appris et tout ce qui est au fondement
de notre démocratie
il ya bien sakania l'idée d'un contrat
et au fond on s'excluent la communauté
des citoyens oms exclus de la communauté
nationale oms exclus de la nationalité
lorsque aux portes les armes contre la
france en commettant un acte terroriste
le principe est clair ensuite ces
modalités juridiques elle elle suscite
un débat qui est un débat légitime débat
légitime parce que dans le code civil
est donc dans la loi simple il existe
déjà
vous le savez des cas de retrait de
perte ou de déchéance de la nationalité
française
alors le gouvernement le président de la
république qui vient devant nous
l'assemblée le sénat avec un texte qui
suscite débat parce qu'il doit être
nécessairement retravailler il ya
plusieurs questions qui se posent et je
vais m'arrêter là en listant le champ
d'application
question le vecteur constitutionnel ou
loi ordinaire sur le champ d'application
de quel français parle-t-on nous sommes
nombreux à penser que tous les français
dès lors qu'il commette un acte de
terrorisme doivent faire l'objet de
cette mesure de retrait de la
nationalité
c'est pas ce qu écrit le gouvernement
dans son projet de loi constitutionnelle
le gouvernement évoque les français nés
français d'une part et d'autre part
ayant une autre nationalité
c'est comme ça que c'est écrit peut-être
doit-on retravaillé cela est envisagé
une autre rédaction
s'appliquant à l'ensemble des français
c'est une vraie question que nous aurons
au bureau politique mercredi et que nous
aurons aussi devant l'assemblée et
devant le sénat c'est une question
constitutionnelle
c'est aussi sans être trop technique on
n'est pas en commission mais quand même
c'est aussi une question de droit
international et le sujet des deux
textes internationaux que la france a
signé mais qu'elle n'a pas ratifié
s'agissant des réduction des cas
d'apatridie qui est un sujet lourd au
plan juridique
au plan pratique au plan symbolique
première can
sur-le-champ deuxième question sur le
champ de quelle infraction on parle le
gouvernement dans le projet de loi
constitutionnelle mentionne les crimes
portant une atteinte grave à la vie de
la nation
c'est une catégorie qui n'existe pas
dans le code pénal
ça suscite donc un débat légitime de
quoi parle-t-on dans le code pénal
on connaît les actes de terrorisme des
articles entiers qui sont consacré on
connaît les atteintes aux intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation c'est une
catégorie juridique les atteintes graves
à la vie de la nation ça n'existe pas
dans le code pénal
de quoi parle-t-on le gouvernement
précise cela que le garde des sceaux
si elle daigne participer au débat
parlementaire sur cette question nous
éclaire de ses lumières
symantec ne soit pas une âme obscurci
par son opposition à la réforme qu'elle
est censée défendre
donc voilà il ya quand même un champ sur
les infractions de quoi parle t-on ça
c'est un vrai sujet on est plutôt dans
l'idée simple que tous les actes
qualifiés juridiquement de terrorisme
d'atteinte aux intérêts fondamentaux de
la nation qui aujourd'hui entraîne la
déchéance de nationalité prévue par le
code civil tout ce champ là sans doute
c'est ce champ là qu'il faut qu'il faut
appréhender pour mettre hors d'état de
nuire des individus qui veulent nous
détruire
et puis dernière question je le disais
la question du vecteur constitutionnel
ou législatif c'est une question qui
là aussi doit faire l'objet de
précisions de la part du du gouvernement
il a choisi une voie peut-être y
avait-il une autre plus directement
opérationnels et je vais conclure là
dessus ce qui compte c'est l'efficacité
s'agit pas de faire débat de philosophie
politique ou un débat d'esthétique
juridique on est pas la section de
l'intérieur du conseil d'état qui est
une assemblée très respectable mais
c'est pas le sujet du jour et on n'est
pas non plus en train de faire une
conférence à sciences po
on est là pour protéger les français que
l'on appartienne au gouvernement au
parlement à l'opposition ou à la
majorité
il faut être efficace et pratique
conforme à nos principes mais efficace
et pratique
et c'est vrai je vais m'arrêter ici
vraiment j'ai rejet je m'arrête en une
phrase on a quand même le sentiment
d'avoir été saisi d'un brouillon voilà
toutes ces questions qui sont à l'esprit
de chacun d'entre nous qui sont dans le
débat public sont des questions
légitimes et sans doute aurait-elle dû
être tranchée un peu avant
voilà pour le moment non mais par
rapport à ce que je disais en
introduction c'est évident que ce que
vient de dire guillaume comme ce qu'a
dit rachida et je vais donner tout de
suite la parole olivier ça prouve que on
peut pas nous dire la réforme
constitutionnelle voilà le texte
vous le prenez vous laisser c'est
évident que ça pose un certain nombre de
questions qui aura un débat qui aura des
amendements chacun s'exprimera mais ce
que l'on dit très clairement au
gouvernement c'est ne partait pas du
principe que sous couvert de l'idée que
nous avons dit initialement que nous
étions favorables à la déchéance
favorable à l'état d'urgence ça veut
dire que on va se taire qui aura pas de
débat pas d'amendement et comprendra le
texte tel quel à gauche comme à droite
un débat parlementaire et l'attitude du
gouvernement sera essentiel sur le vote
final
olive
merci religion est très très bref j'ai
bien compris on veut de l'opérationnel
sur cette réforme constitutionnelle
c'est ce sera notre seul critère
d'appréciation de l'opérationnel alors
on a de quoi que mais m être un peu
méfiant échaudés par rapport à ce que
nous présente le gouvernement et le
président de la république notamment je
pense aux précédents du bracelet
électronique pour s'assurer de
l'effectivité de l'assignation à
résidence
l'andra public s'était dit ouvert le
premier ministre l'a repris en son
compte dans le texte de loi qui était
subi pour prolonger l'état d'urgence
dans la réalité des faits je pense je
laisse faire la vérification mais je
pense que la rédaction retenue par le
gouvernement et telle qu'elle ne
permettra aucune mise en oeuvre
effective dans aucune situation de ce
fameux bracelet électronique donc on est
ce petit rappel sur une actualité
récente pour vous dire qu'on est un peu
échaudé sur ce qui nous est proposé
la comédie guillaume l'atteinte à la vie
de la nation c'est une notion qui pour
l'instant n'existe pas et ne renvoie à
rien donc il est indispensable qu'elle
renvoie à quelque chose que nous
connaissions dans le meilleur délai le
texte de loi qui viendra compléter
puisque ce qu'on modifie c'est l'article
34 de la constitution c'est
l'habilitation du législateur à étendre
cette déchéance de nationalité pour
l'instant ça renvoie à rien cette notion
d'atteinte grave à la vie de l'état
alors que le gouvernement avait la
possibilité de retenir une rédaction qui
elles existent qui étaient les crimes
contre contre l'état c'est le livre iv
du code pénal qui vise tous les actes de
crimes de guerre de génocide actes de
terrorisme
ça n'a pas été le choix du gouvernement
donc évidemment il y a tout un débat qui
n'est pas seulement un débat juridique
mais qui est un véritable débat sur
l'opérationnalité rien ne serait pire
que d'utiliser ce grand mot de déchéance
de nationalité qui ouvre des débats
extrêmement violent à gauche vous l'avez
vu on prend je fais le terme de
déchéance de nationalité était revenu
dans le débat politique au moment du
discours de grenoble donc aujourd'hui
repris par le président de la république
actuel je comprend effectivement que ça
suscite une certaine émotion mes
émotions mais rien ne serait pire que
d'utiliser cette expression de
l'inscrire dans la constitution et qu'en
réalité derrière il ne se passe rien
aucune mesure où presque complémentaire
ne soit dans soit tiré le premier sujet
deuxième sujet très très rapidement vous
savez qu'il y à l'assemblée nationale
une instance de suivi sur les mesures
liées à l'état d'urgence qui est
co-piloté par le président hugo as et
notre collègue jean frédéric poisson on
regarde les chiffres avec beaucoup
d'attention le dernier bilan qui a été
fait date je crois du 21 décembre
faisait état de 2540 perquisitions sur
ces 2540 perquisition évoqué de mémoire
500 infractions relevé ce conseil au
jour d'aujourd'hui c'est que sur ces 500
infractions relevées c'est à dire en
clair c'était généralement des armes
trouvées chez les ch et des gens il n'ya
que 249 poursuites judiciaires ou
condamnations qui ont été qui ont été
enclenchées donc c'est évidemment c'est
évidemment un sujet quand même de la
tension extrême de notre part très
précisément 188 poursuite et 60 et une
condamnation donc il reste il reste du
travail à accomplir en évidemment très
vigilant là-dessus deuxième chiffre
extrêmement inquiétant que roger a donné
tout à l'heure c'est un chiffre qui a
été communiqué par le premier ministre
lui-même lors de sa présentation du
projet de loi constitutionnelle de 23
des 100 d'expliquer qu'on avait franchi
le cap des 1000 français partis faire le
djihad en syrie ou en irak et que sur
ces 1000 français 250 était revenu donc
évidemment la question que nous posons
au gouvernement au premier ministre mais
évidemment aussi derrière à la garde des
sceaux qui est rappelle que le parc est
à l'origine des à l'origine des
poursuites quel sont les poursuites
judiciaires engagées contre ces 250
personnes évident que le premier vecteur
de danger pour la sécurité de nos france
de nos concitoyens aujourd'hui c'est la
présence le retour de ces cinquante
personnes qui se sont volontairement
battu contre contre toutes nos valeurs
toutes les valeurs de la république et
damnation donc qu'elles sont des
poursuites que le gouvernement
entend faire engager par par les
parquets par le parquet antiterroriste
contre contre ces personnes
je m'appelle là aussi un que que le code
pénal que le livre iv du code pénal
prévoit toutes sortes d'incrimination
pour crimes de guerre pour génocide et à
ce jour je n'ai toujours pas vu
d'instruction de madame la garde des
sceaux
évoquant le vote qu'il fallait
poursuivre ces personnes là sur ces
incriminations grave
pourtant c'est un vrai c'est sans doute
la réalité quand il fait là bas si ce
n'est participé à des crimes de guerre
ou à des actions de deux génocides
dernier dernier petit petit point sur la
question qui nous tient très à coeur
aussi des questions des effectifs là
aussi c'est la crédibilité de la parole
publique qui est en cause c'est vrai que
depuis le début du quinquennat le
gouvernement affiche comme une sorte de
slogan la création de 500 postes par an
dans la police dans la gendarmerie la
réalité je vois quand nos confrères du
monde a rédigé un article ya quelques
semaines sur ce sujet là avec guillaume
larrivé nous avions été très attentif
dans le débat budgétaire la réalité ce
qu'on est plutôt à moins de 1000
effectifs dans la police et la
gendarmerie depuis le début du
quinquennat
donc non seulement on n'est pas au plus
5 millions mais au moins 2000 mais le
président de la république en a remis
une couche lors de son débat là dessus
du congrès pardon à versailles en
annonçant la création de 5000 emplois
supplémentaires disant je le cite
caisses du monde mémoire au total au
bout du quinquennat ça fera dix mille
emplois supplémentaires voilà au jour
d'aujourd'hui on en est donc extrêmement
loin on attend là aussi des précisions
je rappelle ce sujet le même peu près
pour les douanes où le gouvernement
annonce et 550 renfort dans les douanes
plusieurs syndicats ont immédiatement
réagi en disant que ses 550 emplois
n'existe probablement pas voilà donc la
conclusion de tout ça c'est que le
le président de la république le premier
ministre nous ont dit nous ont rappelés
et ils n'ont pas tort que nous sommes en
guerre
mais ici nous sommes en guerre et bien
les mesures qui doivent être prises
doivent être à la hauteur et de 2,4 en
tout et en tout état de cause
efficace et opérationnel
eh bien je suis sûr que vous voilà
totalement éclairé